bill you've got a big idea over the next
15 years the lives of people in poor
countries will improve faster than at
any other time in history what makes you
so confident about making a prediction
like that there's a lot in the pipeline
whether it's medicines or the way people
bank or get educated and we're seeing
that people care about these issues and
our ability to communicate and draw
people in is better than ever before and
so that's our our bat is that this next
15 years will be fundamental for the
basics kids surviving people having a
bank account this will be a period of
incredible improvement for a country to
do well you've got to get the nutrition
of its citizens the health of its
citizens the education level of citizens
the financial empowerment up to a
certain level and so by having these
tools some of which are are vaccines
some of which are mobile phone-based
delivery then the lives they lead the
economy really will be self-sufficient
what specifically has changed in the 15
years since you and Melinda started the
foundation to create breakthrough
opportunities in the next 15 years well
the child to death is one where there
have been a lot of work done before we
got involved during these 15 years and
that rolled out and so since 1990 that's
been cut in half now we have those
vaccines some of which are just starting
to get out some of which are still in
the lab that given the full 15 years
we'll be able to get those to all of the
world's children so scientific
understanding keeps advancing
understanding HIV malaria all these
different diseases understanding
nutrition what kind of seeds are
productive what kind of diet do you have
to have how do you teach farmers to grow
more than one crop a year and and use
variety to maximize their output the
amount they can sell for and and what
they themselves rate
to eat what's more important would you
say technological innovation awareness
and support for what you're doing or the
sheer amount of money that is being
invested in the kinds of programs that
you support all of those are pretty
important it's almost like you have to
multiply them together you know without
the science we couldn't make the better
seeds or the vaccines or have digital
money without the donor and generosity
actually getting these things out to
those who need them the most it just
wouldn't happen there's no market
mechanism the vaccines would be going to
the kids who are at the least risk of
getting sick and not at all to those who
have a very high risk of getting sick
but to have government's come up with
that money you need this broad awareness
you need them encouraging their
governments that even though these
people are far away and not often seen
and these deaths are kind of one at a
time it's not this one-day tragedy that
does grab people it's this ongoing set
of tyreel deaths or pneumonia deaths
that if you have an awareness of that
and see that it can be caught then
you'll volunteer time you might give
some money but most importantly you'll
make sure your government takes some of
its resources even 1% would be very
generous and and gets that out to to
poor countries bill if you look back on
the first 15 years of the Gates
Foundation what in retrospect would you
say was the best decision that you made
or the smartest thing that you did I
think we've learned a lot in the 15
years and so you know maybe that has
been the most valuable thing the biggest
impact we've had so far has been in
childhood health we created in the year
2000 this group called gobby has saved
over 10 million lives and a lot of kids
who would have been sick and not fully
developed even if they'd survived the
vaccines that have made a big difference
for them so that one's the best you know
and everything else has to be measured
by that that kind of breakthrough
success indeed it's hard to top saving
10 million lives
what was the biggest mistake well a lot
of things required us to get in and try
out pilot programs and see what would
work in education you know the structure
of high schools trying to make it so
they weren't quite so big we saw some
benefits there but that loan wasn't
enough how you get teachers more
feedback about what they're good at and
how they improve lending and be exposed
to other teachers doing things better
that we've gone through many iterations
we have some pilot sites that have done
very very well but still today the
secret to how you raise the average
teacher up to be as good as the the top
10% not yet solved and yet so valuable
and some places where we have have that
result that we do want to figure out how
to scale it up so a lot of things take
more time than I expect how about the
most valuable lesson you learned well
our early years we thought we were so
naive we should just work on our own
invest in science not trying team up and
influence joint strategies as we got
further down the learning curve
particularly in health then we saw that
we needed to come together with the
government aid budgets and the groups in
the field so how you develop those
partnerships whether it's with the UN
groups like UNICEF and WH o country
groups like USAID the nonprofit groups
like MSF or Care Save the Children
building on our complementary strengths
where we understand Rd better than than
these groups they understand the field
better than we do how you make all that
come together that kind of partnership
model it's been a huge learning curve
and I do think we're we're far better at
it now than ever what in your opinion is
the best way to narrow the inequality
gap by raising taxes on the wealthy or
funding programs to reduce poverty and
bringing people up in the bottom well if
you look at the world
whole it is less an equal more equal now
than in the past and that's because poor
countries like India or China have had
growth rates including wealth growth
rates way above that of the the rich
countries within individual countries
though the inequality has gone up in
almost every country and there I think
everyone believes in a balance that you
should have progressive taxation that if
you get wealthier your consumption your
income your state ought to be subject to
much higher taxes than say the middle
class and you know I personally think
the US could be even more progressive in
that but the thing most people would
emphasize that is critical is the equal
opportunity that if the inner-city
schools are really really good and the
access to health so that that's not
holding people back or social services
that that's strong enough so that we can
say you know every kid has a near equal
chance of becoming a lawyer doctor going
to a good school that is even better
because that's about freedom and that's
about developing capacity as opposed to
a zero-sum transfer now you have to be
able to fund the things that create that
opportunity and taxes are absolutely
necessary so it's those two operating
together taxes to fund it and then the
execution I'll say have that equal
opportunity we don't have equal
opportunity it's what we aspire to as a
country but education alone is so poor
if you grow up in the inner city
compared to the suburbs that it we're
not being true to our our basic credo
much of the monetary policy we've seen
since the financial crisis has been
motivated by aims ostensibly as Noble as
yours reviving the economy creating jobs
keeping families in their homes
in the financial situation for as many
people as possible
did it work well when you have the
aftermath of a the collapse of a credit
bubble ironically part of what you're
trying to do is get people not to be too
conservative and so you're encouraging
them to spend you even want mortgages to
be cheap again the world economy is
coming back somewhat the eurozone still
has has a challenge because of that
their ability to manage very different
economic results within the framework of
a single currency and no common fiscal
policy but the u.s. is exhibit a that
spending has gone up and the job markets
gone up it was slow and a financial bust
is much more likely is gonna be slower
than a business cycle bust and so people
are starting to feel pretty good that if
nothing else comes along that you know
we'll be on a upward growth path there
are some people lots of people in fact
who say that the Cure is as bad as the
disease that quantitative easing in
particular disproportionately benefited
the wealthy and didn't really do that
much for the poor or for that matter for
the middle class are they right well
quantitative easing is technique you use
that when you want to stimulate spending
business investment consumer investment
and you've gotten interest rates
essentially to zero if you want to bring
out bring down the the price of assets
going out into the future the interest
rate it's a tool that's been used it
actually helps debtors at the expense of
savers and so in general if you have a
savings account you're getting very
little whereas it as a debtor you can
roll your debts over at low interest now
it does tend to make financial assets
all capital assets houses stocks look
more valuable relative to the risk-free
interest rate so you do get the stock
market going up it's
done a to favor one level of wealth
versus another level it's done for the
general economy only tax policy can take
your level of inequality and being very
you know in particular at causing some
adjustment there